[Music]
how do you define AI
oh that's a that's a controversial
question I feel like this is a pretty
hard question I think this AI is
definitely an overloaded term even
amongst researchers who supposedly
research AI at AI artificial
intelligence is the idea that we can
teach a computer to replicate some
things may or eventually all things that
humans consider intelligence I think the
term AI gets a little bit overloaded
especially in the news so for me when
most people say AI they actually mean
machine learning which is just pattern
recognition from seeing a whole bunch of
previous data
I think AI is the culmination of any
sorts of techniques that allow computers
to solve complicated tasks without
humans having to manually specify
solutions or really precise algorithms
AI is essentially I like to think of
intelligence as the ability to process
information to inform future decisions
and AI is the ability to build
artificial algorithms to do exactly that
process information to inform the future
decisions I'm still trying to figure
that one out yep
[Music]